[Applause]
[Music]
pedro castillo candidate of peru libre a
left-wing marxist party won the second
round of the 2021 presidential elections
in peru during the campaign this
candidate raised the possibility of
nationalizing companies ending the
funded pension model penalizing imports
suspending free trade agreements among
many other issues
so how on earth did pedro castillo win
the elections how could peruvians vote
for such a leader well
basically because beyond whether or not
there were irregularities with one or
another ballot what is certain is that
the castile government garnered
enormous popular support and yes the
easiest answer would be to say that he
won because his opponent kiko fujimori
daughter of a former dictator alberto
fujimori was a very bad candidate
perhaps also because of covet 19. after
all peru's management of the pandemic
has been one of the worst
in the world in 2020 the country had the
worst record in terms of death per
million along with one of the most
severe economic recessions however
wait just a minute because the truth is
is that there is more much more and that
that's precisely what we want to look at
in this video
[Music]
how is it possible that peru one of the
rock stars of latin america during the
last two decades has now decided to vote
for a president who mentions
marxism nationalizations and again once
again in latin america
import substitution that is to say a
president who seems to want to go back
to the plan
the strategy the policy that so often
failed the countries of latin america
and who
even more incomprehensibly returns again
and again and again to the region's
political front page
but what on earth is going on to make
latin america
not want to leave poverty behind why
don't they just copy what works
if only copying were enough so the
question the big question we can ask
ourselves is
what is behind the pedro castillo
victory what can explain the return once
again
of marxist politicians to the forefront
of latin american politics we're gonna
answer all those questions today so
let's get cracking
[Music]
when peru failed
in 2017 we published a video called peru
major power in latin america it was one
of the first videos we made about this
region of the world and you know what
at that time everything indicated that
this andean peaceful and amazonian
country was going to take over the world
the numbers were
so good that they seemed almost
impossible for things to not go well do
you want some proof well take note of
this
since the year 2000 the country has
registered the second highest economic
growth rate
in all of latin america since that same
year 2000 annual investment had
multiplied by five times and the
government's accounts were among the
healthiest on the entire
planet we are talking about an economic
evolution that had reduced poverty by
less than half from levels above 50
to just over 20 of the population in
just 15 years
[Music]
so with such data peru seems poised to
jump right into the all-stars club of
the most prosperous countries with
healthy public accounts
many new companies sprouting up all over
the country average goes above 5
inflation under control and foreign
capital pouring in everything seemed
poised for the national economy to rival
the take-off successes of the most
booming asian economies
peru has become one of the countries
with the most free trade agreements
in the world agreements that give free
access to all the major economies
on the planet the united states china
the european union japan south korea the
united kingdom canada
and australia among many others in total
to give you an idea peru has free trade
agreements with more than
80 percent of the world's economy a
policy that allowed the country to
multiply its exports by almost
six times between 2000 and 2019 which
obviously meant a huge and
ever-increasing inflow of foreign
currency
so with such a scenario the question i
am convinced many of you are wondering
right now is
what on earth happened for things to go
suddenly so wrong
in peru
well here let's take a minute because
the truth is that all this prosperity
began to run aground in 2016 and little
by little what had been going full steam
ahead and at full speed
started to slow down more and more for
example while between 2005 and 2009 the
country averaged an annual growth rate
of 6.5
between 2010 and 2014 that figure had
dropped to 5.8
between 2015 and 2019 it fell to only
3.2
a level not sufficient to continue
reducing poverty for example
and indeed after more than 20 years of
strong growth in 2019
70 of the peruvian population had not
been able to move up a level
70 infrastructure at all levels remains
dire and perceived prosperity seemed to
be going downhill and then
to top it all off along came the corona
virus which
was the straw that broke the camel's
back and at this point i know perfectly
well what the question on the tip of
your tongue is but
grant what the hell happened in peru how
did a candidate like castile manage to
win a popular majority well
check this out
[Music]
institutional disloyalty
we can talk about 2000 2005 2011 or
practically
any of peru's recent years and the truth
is that the story would not change much
however
there was one nuance things have gotten
worse and 2016 was kind of like a
starting gun for a macabre countdown to
self-destruction okay i don't want to
exaggerate too much but let's just say
that 2016 ushered in a new turbulent
stage politically
socially and even economically in that
year elections were held and the results
could not have been more complex in the
presidential elections pedro pablo
kaczynski won the second round by just
over 40 000 votes against kiko fujimori
however
in the legislative elections the result
was totally different fuerza popular
kiko's party won 73 of the 130 seats
this was more than half of the deputies
while the ppk
the president's party barely won 18. and
that is when
things started to go from bad to worse
on the one hand
in the face of any hint of political
responsibility foreign popular decided
to go an all
out against the kozinski government the
parliament thus became a hostile terrain
for the government itself which as you
can imagine meant impeding many of the
changes that the government wanted to
lead and
at times the harassment was seriously
rough political responsibility peru's
interests first don't make me laugh
of course wait a minute because that was
just the beginning
soon afterwards a political bombshell
was to turn the whole country upside
down in december of that same year 2016
the anti-corruption unit of the peruvian
attorney general's office ordered an
investigation
into kuczynski's possible relationship
with the brazilian construction company
oberet yes that infamous company that
has practically bought
all of the politicians in latin america
[Music]
but that was not all a year after the
prosecutor's office began its
investigations the lava jato commission
on the peruvian congress showed evidence
of the relationship between kaczynski
and the brazilian construction company
when the former was finance minister
according to these reports a company
owned by kozinski and based in miami
westfield received several contracts
from obrecht in 2004. shortly after the
construction company received a
guarantee that the peruvian state would
assume the economic risks derived from
the almost energy and irrigation project
in the region of lambayik we are talking
about a guarantee of almost
500 million dollars for a private
initiative seems legit right
[Applause]
in other words basically if the company
made money with the almost project it
would increase
its profits but if the venture resulted
in
losses then the peruvian government
would pay and that's
how obrecht does business the fact is
from that moment on a whole political
war began and on the 15th of december
2017 the peruvian congress allowed the
proceeding of a first request for a
presidential vacancy for those of you
who don't know the vacancy is a process
by which the peruvian legislature the
congress can remove the president from
office by invoking his moral or physical
incapacity in a nutshell with the
vacancy the congress can fire the
president it can send him
to hell
in any case the move did not go forward
among other reasons because kaczynski
made a pact with kiyoko fujimori's
brother kenji fujimori for his support
along with that of some other
congressmen in exchange for pardoning
their father alberto frijimori something
that kazinsky followed up through
just a few days later it was a decision
that provoked massive
protest and the resignation of three
ministers but it did not stop there with
more evidence that congress tried a new
vacancy process
and this time some videos surfaced of
kenji fujimori trying to bribe
congressmen with the promise of public
works contracts in exchange for voting
against opposing the president
[Music]
kozinski a leader who had arrived to the
presidency on a discourse of
change a message and fresh ideas that
even earned him one of the visual
politic awards ended up resigning on the
21st of march 2018. i guess
plans don't always work out and even we
can sometimes make mistakes
but the worst thing the absolute worst
thing is that the kunzinski government
started a
massive campaign that was later
continued by his successor martin
viscara accusing the congress of
perpetrating a coup d'etat despite the
fact that vacancy is a fully
constitutional procedure in case you're
wondering what happened to him
vizcarra by the way was later ousted for
corruption allegations as well and once
again
in the midst of huge protests in total
there were four presidents in one term
of office and so you say
what's the problem with that grant well
let's see on one hand this type of
behavior generates enormous disgrace and
distrust towards the institutions both
among peruvians themselves
and among foreign investors on the other
hand let's not be naive this political
crisis clearly illustrated the real
motivations of peruvian politicians who
make up the first line of command
motivations that have
nothing to do with the general interests
they are public representatives who have
made it
very clear that they only represent
themselves something we can also see
with the rampant corruption that seems
to affect peruvian politics
and mind you we are not talking about
the usual problem that we can find in
any country where a politician takes
a little bribe not at all
in this case things go much further all
indicators point to the fact that
corruption in peruvian institutions
is common practice surveys indicate that
36 of peruvians consider corruption to
be the most significant problem in their
country over 26 percent say they have
personally suffered from it and more
than 75
of all peruvian citizens consider
corruption to be common among officials
and politicians
in fact according to transparency
international peru has gone from being
the 44th least corrupt country on the
world in 2000 to a position that in
recent years has fluctuated between
106th
and 94th place so well done peru
to make matters worse all of these
political games divert attention to
issues that have nothing to do with
promoting peru's prosperity and that
that has consequences
target and the passive state
during the last 20 years peru has
registered an important economic
improvements that among other things
have increased the state's income a
state that has not ceased to increase
its public employees in many cases
though and what is known as the tar head
azo that is
to place relatives friends and cronies
of all kinds in roles on the state's
payroll what is worse all this increase
in public employees has not translated
into a real improvement in the
functioning of the public treasury
the major problems of 10 years ago are
basically the same as they are today and
to make matters worse the one thing that
has grown during this time
is the bureaucracy of course all these
new employees will have to do
something but what exactly are the
problems we are
talking about well let's take a look at
that now
[Music]
despite having enviable financial health
the country's lack of infrastructure is
so pronounced that according to the
world economic forum the quality of
infrastructure only just ranks above
that of venezuela bolivia and paraguay
we were talking about a gap that some
recent estimates place it some
300 billion dollars which obviously has
a knock-on effect in terms of economic
activity
and believe me anyone who's been to peru
knows exactly what we are talking about
next the financial sector is so
underdeveloped and so close to
competition the peruvians find it very
difficult to access financing and suffer
much higher rates which in turn hurts
investment to give you an idea small
loans with rates of 20
30 or even 40 are not uncommon in fact
what is known as the bank spread that is
the margin with which banks work is more
than 14
compared to just over three percent in
oecd countries and that's not all
to make matters worse only seven percent
of companies are able to access bank
financing
likewise the capital markets are
underdeveloped the lima stock exchange
is a joke and the pension system has
been deadlocked and in need of reform
for a long long time for example the
private prevention system which is
similar to chile's model barely covers
of peruvians of working age it's also a
model that is close to competition with
very high commissions that devour the
profitability of the participants
as for the public sector it's almost
better not to talk about it the average
monthly pension is a little more than
150 us dollars a month and for those who
are lucky enough to receive it
because among other things you have to
have worked for more than 20 years to be
eligible to collect a single peso
[Music]
[Applause]
in total the private and public pension
system barely covers 30
of peruvians over the age of 65. the
rest either receive some small subsidy
from the pension 65 program or nothing
at
all which is exactly what happens to
more than 40 percent of the elderly
[Music]
in addition the public companies are a
disaster they are barely capable of
investing many have become nests of
corruption in some the jobs are even
inherited by union agreement and they
are certainly
not profitable petro peru for example
accumulated losses of more than 3
billion us dollars over the last decade
that's an
oil company losing money on a sustained
basis over time you know that when i'm
talking about something like that
unfortunately i'm definitely talking
about latin america and we could go on
education is very poor urban planning is
so outdated that since 2001 more than 90
of urgent expansion has been carried out
in a regular if not outright illegal
manner in the countryside which
generates more than 30
of all the jobs in the country the
majority of people remain in subsistence
conditions without support in training
mechanization or development of
cooperatives and associations
and of course this is just not gonna
work it's a situation that
by the way favors coca plantations as an
alternative in fact peru is the second
largest cocaine producer
in the world coca cultivation in peru
expands to 72 000 hectares according to
the white house
peru is the world's second largest
cocaine producer after colombia it's the
same
old story but you know what all these
issues seem to take a backseat to the
antics of peruvian politicians and
that's despite the fact that they end up
having very significant social
and economic consequences
do you want an example well it's
estimated that there are between 25 and
50 billion dollars tied up in mining
projects that have been put on hold due
to the social rejection
simply because the government has not
had the leadership to seek formulas that
favor
local communities we are talking about a
potentially enormous source of wealth
that in countries where things are done
well such as australia for example
has led to enormous general prosperity
[Music]
and yes the bad press on mining is
understandable in the past
many abuses were allowed in exchange for
the benefits remember what we were
saying about bribes in the country well
maybe that had something to do with it
the point is is that the country does
not promote innovation the investment
attraction policy is insufficient and
there is no development of strategic
zones or hubs of activity the peruvian
government has sound finances yes but it
does not seem to know how to do
anything else it seems to be moving
forward on a kind of autopilot that is
already clearly insufficient for driving
development
which allows many sectors to be in the
hand of an elite that protects itself
from competition
[Music]
at the end of the day in corrupt
environments where only the political
survival counts the selection of leaders
and professionals is not based on
meritocracy but above all on
loyalty this leads to an increasingly
poor level of management this in turn
feeds the lack of ability to implement
measures as well as the lack of honesty
and transparency let's not fool
ourselves peru's biggest problem
is not pedro castillo peru's biggest
problem is what
has led a politician like estee to win
the elections so at this point the
question is
will castile be a danger to peru it
certainly doesn't look great although
in the end it might not come too much
we've been wrong before castillo does
not have a parametric majority and it's
not unreasonable to think that he'll be
more like former peruvian president
humala than the likes of say hugo chavez
there will be no expropriations there
will be no nationalizations we will not
take away anyone's property or
savings we want a popular economy with
markets the independence of the central
bank will be respected because it has
done a good job of keeping
inflation low we are not following the
bolivarian idea we want to disprove it
pedro frank economic adviser to pedro
castillo in any case a side note the
fact like messages like his dominate
peruvian politics does not bode well and
the risk is clearly on the table but
let's not fool ourselves the problem had
already taken root and it is the
politicians themselves who have turned
peruvian institution
into their own amusement park but what
did you think the future holds for peru
under castillo's leadership leave us
your answer in the comments below and as
always
don't forget to like us and subscribe to
visualpolitik take it easy
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you